[Arabic recitation]
we will
review some of the very briefly
some of the meanings
of a narration in which the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
places a condition
and makes a promise.
And if we were to really look at the
Quran,
really look at the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
What is the Quran?
Allah refers to the books that he has
sent down
as
his me
his allegiance
and his
oath that is taken between himself and
his servants.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sums this oath
up and this allegiance and he says
fulfill my oath
fulfill your allegiance
and I shall fulfill mine.
The Quran is a book of hope and it is an
allegiance,
an agreement between Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and his slaves
that these are the conditions.
This is what is expected of you.
And the more you hold to this oath and
this allegiance,
the
more you will receive from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in return
because Allah is far more gracious and
far more generous
than his creation subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He is the essence and founder of
generosity subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We are told by the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam in this narration
the bare minimum
upon which the human being begins his
ascent
into the levels of paradise.
What is the foundation
upon which our agreement, our allegiance
to Allah is founded?
What is the foundation
of this allegiance?
Our prophet sallall.aii Wasallam says in
this narration,
[Silence]
This narration is in Bkari Muslim
as we've mentioned before the highest
level of authenticity.
narrates to us that our prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
said, "Whoever testifies
that none is rightfully worshiped but
Allah alone without any partners
and that Muhammad is the slave of Allah
and his messenger."
And that Isa
Jesus
is as well the slave of Allah and his
messenger.
and his word which he cast upon Moriam
and a soul
that he has created and a soul from him
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and that paradise is a reality a
tangible truth
and that the hellfire
is a literal tangible truth
Allah will enter him will admit him into
paradise
based on his actions
based on his actions.
So we see here from this narration
that there is a bare minimum
from which a person begins his
relationship with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
So if you can imagine with me the gate
to paradise.
This is what gets a person through the
gate.
A person's actions,
a person's worship,
a person's
dutifulness.
This is what raises the person
within paradise
to reach his or her final abode therein.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
gives us the bare minimum
that a person must have this belief
that this ethos, this creed,
this zubda
or this summary of belief.
This is what our
religion
is based upon upon these testimonies.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam uses
the word.
Notice the wording.
He uses the word menid.
Whoever testifies
testimony
in Arabic and in English.
A testimony
is only of that which a person has seen.
When a person testifies to something in
Arabic,
the word shahida,
that a person
testifies. Imagine that you are in a
court of law
and you are called as a witness to
testify.
Testimony
is only referred to as such when it
involves what a person has witnessed.
meaning what a person has seen, what a
person has heard, what a person has felt
or experienced.
And so these things here for us for
instance
the testimony
of belief in Allah belief in the prophet
belief in the prophet Muhammad Sam
belief in Isaam
etc.
this testimony. We have not seen Allah.
We have not even met the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
We have not met Isa.
We're testifying that paradise is a
truth and a reality. The hellfire is
truth and a reality. We have seen
neither place.
So the question is how is it that we are
called to testify
the word here the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam didn't use the word believe
here he didn't say whoever believes
that none is rightfully worship but
Allah and that Muhammad is the messenger
of Allah etc. Rather the words that he
used
was testimony. Whoever testifies
because
this is beyond mere.
We will not ever see in the sunnah in
the Quran that the word
used the word testify is used. It
is not whoever trusts that none is
rightfully worshiped but Allah. No, the
word testimony
meaning that there is nothing a person
is more sure of.
This testimony is so deeply entrenched
in the person's heart
that it is as if they have seen paradise
for themselves and can testify there
that paradise is the truth that the
hellfire is the truth. They can testify
to this because it is not just that they
merely believe.
It is not just that they merely have to.
No, they testify
and a person testifies only to that
which they have bear borne witness to.
[Arabic recitation]
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam uses.
It teaches us the level of belief that
the believers have. And because of these
types of words and because of this
the scholars of Islam have defined for
us what eman is,
what belief is. When Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says belief,
belief in Allah in the last day, it's
not just that a person has, you know, I
trust that Allah exists and the last day
shall come to pass. No, rather this is
a belief that is
originating in the core
of a person's soul.
And because of that, the scholars of
Islam have defined Eman
as being far beyond just trusting or
believing. Rather,
[Silence]
The scholars have defined e and they say
and we will end with this that eman
is belief in the heart
stating as such statement of the tongue
action of the body and limbs. It
increases
with the obedience of alman and it
decreases
with every obedience of aanala.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
While early he was happy.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
I am your son.
[Silence]
I am.
Hey,
[Silence]
I
Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
Heat.
All
[Silence]
right.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Muslim.
for you.
[Silence]
Allah
formed.
[Silence]
Wasam.
What the
museum?
for
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
regarding the people of the book.
The people of the book
who were
referred to as the people of the book
because this is a distinction
from the rest of the people
in the community or in the society that
our prophet sallall.aii
Wasam was sent to
there were people who were idoltors,
pagans. They worshiped idols and claimed
to be upon the
natural religion of Ibraimis.
And then there were the people of the
book,
people of knowledge,
people who were given messengers and
prophets
and given a book from Allah that were
his words subhanala
directing him directing them to him and
to his pleasure.
Those followers of Misam,
those followers of Isaam
are referred to in the Quran as people
of the book
so as to distinguish them from the rest
of the pagans that
lived during the time of the
revelation of the Quran to our prophet
sallallahu alaihi Wasam.
It's a great honor the people of the
book.
This statement, this word, it
articulates knowledge. It articulates
guidance, scholarship.
And so the people of the book,
they are dwelled upon and mentioned
throughout the Quran often, time and
time again.
Why?
Because the people who were given the
book before us
the followers of Musam,
the followers of Isaam,
those who claimed to be followers of MS
and Isa and the other prophets and
messengers of Ben is
they were numerous and they made a lot
of mistakes.
They made many, many, many mistakes.
And so
for us to learn,
for us to avoid such mistakes,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us
those mistakes meticulously
in detail
throughout the Quran so that we may be
able to avoid the pitfalls
that those who tread the path before us
fell victim to
our prophet sallall.aii
warns us
in
he says you will follow the ways
of those who came before you
meaning the people of the book those
nations that preceded us
when he says you all will it doesn't
mean all of the Muslim
and it doesn't even mean most of the
Muslim.
But it does mean that because the
prophet Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam's
nation is the greatest of nations. It is
the most numerous of nations and it is
the last nation.
Members and followers of this nation
will inevitably fall into mistakes that
were make made before us.
And he warns us Sam. Wasam
that we will fall into the mistakes
meaning some of the Muslim will make the
same mistakes that nations that preceded
us made.
He says these mistakes will be
remarkable in their similarity.
Ala
in the Arabic language is the feather.
The feathers that are found at the end
of an arrow.
When they put feathers
at the end of an arrow in order to make
it fly straight and true,
these feathers are meticulously put into
a straight row, usually a row of two,
two rows or four or three.
But these
strands of feathers, if you will, these
individual feathers hairs, they are
put in a row, a straight single file
robe.
And so the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam is giving us
imagery of just how close our mistakes
will be to the mistakes of those who
have preceded us.
Just each strand
of those feathers is placed into a
single file straight row when installed
on an arrow. Likewise will be the demise
of some
of
the Muslim.
He then says sallall.aii Wasam something
very str, very curious, strange,
interesting,
something very strange and that is
even if one of them
even if it is as absurd as one of them
having managed to
stuff himself self into the hole of a
lizard,
someone
somewhere
will manage to follow suit.
How illogical is it? The the hole of a
lizard. Why does he mention the the hole
of a lizard? A desert lizard. They dig a
hole and they go in there and stay.
There's nothing in that hole. There's
nothing in there.
It's small.
It's tight.
There is no use to it. There's nothing
to earn by a person going through the
trouble of stuffing himself into this
hole of a lizard.
Yet, no matter how illogical it may
seem, how ridiculous it is, if one of
them has managed to do so, someone will
follow suit. And this is the nature of
history.
When we look through the Quran, we see
how history repeats itself over and over
and over and over. Each prophet and
messenger coming to his people, warning
them of the demise of the nation that
has just preceded them, yet they still
meet the same fate.
Why?
Because
everybody thinks usually people think
that they're special.
Each person looks at the mistakes made
by those who came before and they say,
"Well, that was them. me. I'm way too
smart to make that kind of mistake.
I am way too special to make that kind
of mistake. And so the mistake is
repeated.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has warned us of the mistakes made by
the people of the book before us that in
spite of them having the guidance and
the book of Allah they still fell victim
to the trappings of a shaitan.
And so our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
warns us.
He warns us so as to protect us, for us
to develop a kind of hyper vigilance
and a particular sensitivity
not just to any misguidance, but
specifically to those misguidances
that
the people of the book before us fell
victim to. One of those trappings
is jealousy.
Envy. But not just any kind of jealousy.
Not just any kind of envy.
Envy
that is cloaked
with a veneer
of love and affection for another.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
surah bakar about the people of the
book.
He says that many of those who were
given the book before you wish that they
could revert you all back to disbelief
after you have believed out of jealousy
and envy for what you all have been
given.
This is an incredible amount of envy and
jealousy
that the people of the book see the
pagan Arabs in the time of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam who worshiped
all of these different gods and all of
these different idols.
They worshiped graves. They worshiped
animals. They worshiped stones and
trees. They worshiped witches and
fortune tellers.
And the people of the book, some of them
are so jealous that if they had it their
way, they would revert the Muslim back
to that state of paganism and idolatry
that they were in out of jealousy and
envy.
That they don't even want people to be
saved, to enter paradise. They'd rather
see people suffer in the misery of
Jahyah.
Now that is some level of jealousy.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
elsewhere in the Quran regarding
many groups of the people of the book
that at first glance
the untrained eye might mistake them as
being together
and as being one and as being united.
But their hearts couldn't be further
apart.
Why does Allah tell us these things?
Again, so we as the Muslim can avoid
these pitfalls.
So that we can diagnose our hearts and
our communities to eradicate
or do the best that we can in
eradicating
the true illnesses that human beings
suffer from not just the symptoms.
So Allah tells us of a jealousy that
exists.
This is a kind of religious jealousy. if
you will,
and it is cloaked with a cheap veneer
of togetherness and unity.
But if we were to go in a little bit
deeper, just past the superficial,
we find that they are very
they are very much
in discord. they are very much
turned against one another and that
unity is incredibly scarce
between them.
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us of such incidents
in Bkari Muslim the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam says that only three children have
spoken
in the cradle.
Only three children have spoken in the
cradle.
And he mentions to us Isaiam being one
of them and another infant child from
amongst many is and he says
or the child from the story of Jo
who was in summary the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
that there was a man named Jo who came
before us
from the people of the book he was aid
he was a monk he was someone who had
married himself to the worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and he had a small s
he had kind of a a it was almost a
tower but it was only two stories. The
bottom story has no doors to it
and the reason for that is he wouldn't
want people to come visit him. He is too
busy in the worship of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
And Jo was a man who really did believe
in Allah and truly desired Allah's mercy
and forgiveness. He was Arabic. He
rarely ever mixed with people. He
remained off in his s his hut made of
mud where he was secluded there and
would worship Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
as much as he could. Our prophet tells
us that once his mother came and called
him while he was in salah.
He heard his mother's voice
and he said to himself contemplating,
"Should I answer my mother or should I
continue my salah?" And she continued to
call him. And he continued to
contemplate this until he said,
I'm going to continue with my prayer.
I'll get to mom later.
And then again, the same thing happened
and the same choice was made. And a
third time and his mother became
frustrated.
And she made a dua that was kind of off
the cuff.
And it was
a dua that she made out of anger. In
a moment of anger,
she said,
she said, "Oh Allah, do not let this boy
die until he looks into the faces of
prostitutes."
Now, this was a statement made out of
anger. her calmer, more resolved self
would not have made such a dua. But she
became frustrated that she could not get
her son to
listen to her, to answer her call, to
tend to her needs.
And that takes precedence over
just random acts of prayer.
And so in A MOMENT OF FRUSTRATION she
made such a happen stance dua. Yet Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala took that dua very
seriously.
J was known amongst the people of many
as being a man of great worship and
integrity. no scandals,
nothing in his past
that would indicate that
anyone should think anything but the
best of Jul.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us that
some of the members of Benel of his
community were in the town talking to
one another. They were just in a
gathering having a conversation and came
up in their conversation.
And so as J's name came up in their
gathering,
they started to talk about how beautiful
Jo is, how great his worship is, what a
good man, what a man of integrity.
And a woman who was one of the
prostitutes, she was a known prostitute
of Benisel
happened to hear them having this
conversation. Now we notice here that
this is the first problem.
We have the best of their community and
the lowest of their community all
gathered in the same place.
They are not choosing their company. And
this is one of the mistakes that Ben is
made that Allah warns us of inah.
She was considered the paragon of
objective beauty.
This woman was incredibly beautiful.
She heard them praising Jes
and she said, "I can seduce J.
If you all allow me to, I can seduce
him. I bet you I could take him off the
path. You're all talking about how
incredibly beautiful George is. I'm sure
I bet you I could make him waver, make
him flounder."
What did his brothers and sisters from
Ben who just A MOMENT AGO WERE praising
him, singing his praises and speaking
about how they wish their kids were like
him and they wish they could be like
Jes. Did they defend him? Did they say
stay away from Jes? Leave him alone.
Don't even test him. No.
What they said was, "Bet.
You think you could take him astray?
Be my guest. Let's see."
This shows a very particular type of
jealousy and envy that the scholars of
Islam mention
that the people of Ben,
this group anyhow, suffered from.
It was this envy
that instead of deterring this woman
with her ill intentions,
they encouraged her to go and try to
seduce George into Zenna. For what
reason? For no other reason that that he
makes them feel insecure about
themselves.
This is not a problem with Jo. this is a
problem within themselves.
He makes them feel insecure.
He reminds them of what they should be
doing
by his mere presence.
And so even though they praise him
outwardly, inwardly as Allah tells us,
their hearts were riddled with envy and
jealousy and malice.
We will
continue to draw insights from this
story that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam has told us and our following
in subsequent
for
[Silence]
Muslim.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Allah. foreign.
All
[Silence]
one for
All.
as
I
[Silence]
suhammed.
He was
alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Nobody
Allah.
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Come
forward as much as possible. Please do
not start a new row or join a row until
you're sure that the row ahead of you is
completely filled. Align your shoulders
and feet with the shoulders and feet of
your two neighbors. Inshallah, after
salat,
we will have a quick salat jaza
over a brother that has passed away in
federal prison. referred you know
he's known as Imam Jim
he passed away a while ago in federal
prison we will have over him so right
after salah we will finish our salah
then I will stand up we will stand
exactly as we are for any normal prayer
as janazi is I will give a very quick
rundown on how janaza is performed
and then I will ask our brother
Hassan inshallah to lead us in janaza
[Arabic recitation]
send me out Lord.
Allahel.
[Silence]
Allah
acel.
[Silence]
We will make janaz
if we could just stand up in exactly the
place that we are exactly as we line up
for any prayer. It just takes about 1
minute janaza
janaza is comprised of four.
After the first there's no there's no
janaza. After the first Allahbar,
we will recite.
Then we will make another Allahbar and
we will make a
just we do in salah after
it is. Then we'll make a third. And here
we make dua for our departed brother.
Make dua for him with whatever comes to
mind in whatever language you are
proficient in. If you have something
memorized of what our prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would say in janaza,
that is better. But any dua
dua, the yard stick to proper dua in
janaza is that you make dua for him as
you would made for you in this
situation because we will all eventually
be that janaz. We will all eventually be
that funeral procession that is
prayed for. Our prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam
said that we are to
dua that we are to make dua for the
person who is deceased and make our dua
specific for them. so make it as
specific as you can. After that we'll
make a fourth and final followed by two
to the right and then to the left. After
that we'll have our president
brother Makud inshallah for the
announcements.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Hello.
Allah
[Silence]
Come on.
Allah.
[Silence]
So just just to expand on on what she
had mentioned. , I jam was originally
incarcerated in Tucson Federal, which is
right down the street from us. , there
had been many protests over the year.
, she man had come down here about a
couple of years ago to protest at the
federal building. We have gone down as
well to ask for his release. in his
last days he was suffering from face
cancer and eventually with all the
protests that we had called into the
prison he was eventually transferred to
Butner which is a federal medical
facility in North Carolina and that's
where he passed away Monday where he
had taken his last breaths. May Allahh
have mercy upon his soul. he was a
true civil rights warrior. May Allahh
accept him in the highest. brothers
was was incarcerated for over some 40 60
50 years. May Allah subhah have immense
mercy upon his soul and his family.
so please keep him in his family duas
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
That's why you're sweat.